[Music]
the subject of the talk is some of the
statistical problems that have arisen in
designing a distributed tracing system
so I will spend some time on the on the
problem context which veers a little bit
towards engineering but I'll try to
spend the bulk of the time on on some of
the pure statistical problems and data
structures that that we've worked on in
in answering these these challenges and
and building this product so a little
bit about myself so actually I was a
graduate student here a very long time
ago so lots of lots of memories I was an
academic mathematician for a while after
finishing a postdoc at USC I decided to
leave her industry for almost four years
now I've been at signal effects where a
real-time monitoring and alerting
monitoring and alerting solution for
time series data a few months ago we
were acquired by Splunk so we're now a
Splunk company a lot of people ask me
how is this been used to be in a
start-up now you're working for a big
company well one thing I've noticed is
that there are many more resources
around in a big company and one of those
resources is of a legal nature and so
out of an abundance of caution I think I
have to put this up for a few seconds so
anyway moving on so after after
mentioning some of the background I'd
like to focus on on three statistical
themes so the the first is various data
structures for doing quantile estimation
and a particular focus on a new version
of a tea digest which we've developed
then I'll discuss the problem of undoing
sampling bias and then I'll say a few
words about how to handle non
stationarity in this in this context ok
so as as you've probably gathered from
from some of the other talks at this
conference and and and and other
conferences much of the world is is
moving towards micro surface micro
services architectures which basically
means that instead of an application
being deployed as a single monolith is
broken up into little pieces that do
some little subset of the work needed to
run the application so some may front
databases some may perform calculations
some may may operate the rest layer but
in general this allows the different
pieces of the application to to scale as
they need rather than scaling the the
infrastructure rather than scaling all
the infrastructure and it's also kind of
needed to handle engineering teams that
that are just working on some small
piece so there there are many many
forces pushing us in this pushing us in
this direction one of the challenges
that arises is that it is not so easy
for a single person to reason about how
work flows through some of these more
complicated architectures and so
distributed tracing is generally viewed
as complement to more traditional
methods like logging and metrics as a
way of offering insight into how work is
flowing through a micro-services
architecture and so I I also I brought
some some traces with me so so here's
one so each each horizontal bar is a
span that's basically a particular
operation in a particular service doing
some work the durations spent is the is
the length of the bar and then there are
also parent-child relationships among
the different operations so some
services may call themselves and then
eventually call other services and in
this case the the different colors
represent that the represent different
services so here the rest layers doing
some work and then it's asking analytics
to to make a calculation analytics has
to setup a job and then eventually
starts querying starts querying a time
series service ok so that's a little a
little chunk of a distributed trace and
then if you zoom out a little bit it
looks it looks like this so fascinating
so a little bit a little bit more about
the data model so the so a span is
basically consists of a start and end
time and then the service and operation
that are involved in doing the work and
of course these can be
with some some additional tags that
capture some of the context of the
execution and there's also some
identifiers we have to do some
accounting the parent ID which allows us
to construct a directed acyclic graph
from one of these executions and also
the ID of the containing trace and so
you can kind of think of this as an
atomic unit of instrumented code and
then a trace is just a collection of
these that share the same the same trace
ID so this is a very brief introduction
to disbands and traces with with some
pictures and so one one problem that
arises you know some of the some of the
larger tech companies that I've
implemented these solutions in-house
have noticed this one of the problems is
that for large applications or
applications that they handle a lot of
traffic this is just a very large amount
of data and it probably doesn't make
sense to store at all there are
definitely cases when it makes sense to
sample it down and so this creates a
problem which we can convert to your
statistics or data science which is how
do we decide which traces to keep any
any questions so far on the on the
context seems fine okay okay so so one
approach is is to flip a coin probably
everyone could have come up with that so
you pick some probability like you know
0.1% and you you keep everybody with
that probability so this does have some
virtues it's very easy to implement like
no one's going to give a talk about this
it's very resource efficient it's very
easy to reason about so you can easily
construct confidence intervals for
example if you if you know the size of
your sample all right there's no
statistical algorithm to maintain in
code there's no issues with distributing
this it's dead simple but of course the
problem is that most executions are
pretty uninteresting and problems don't
announce themselves at the beginning of
the of the execution they sometimes
happen only only towards the end
relatively deep down in the in the
execute in the trace and so this is
kind of kind of clear but just for
concreteness I made an example so now I
have to navigate over so this is this is
an actual trace let's see is it gonna
work okay so this the database is making
a bunch of asynchronous calls
everything's totally fine executing
quickly no errors and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere you know there's a
what basically there is a timeout and
the the Graybar timed out and then the
red bar that bubbles up to an error in
the in the calling operation and so if
you want to have a higher probability of
keeping traces like this then you need
to somehow bias your sampling and this
will require you to buffer the traces
for at least some time because you don't
know in advance whether this is going to
happen so you can't just flip a coin it
you can't just flip a coin that's it at
the beginning of the execution okay now
I have to navigate back over okay that's
the end of the end of the video okay no
sound okay so instead we would like to
take a tale based approach which means
that we defer the sampling decision
until the trace completes by the way
trace completion is not a well-defined
thing right spans complete but traces
don't actually complete and then show a
preference for for interesting traces
okay and so what are some you know
heuristics that come from come from this
business context so what makes a trace
interesting well latency is interesting
so a span or a trace that takes longer
than it's supposed to is interesting
could reveal some problem span or trace
that has an error on it especially if
the error rate is generally very low for
that operation or endpoint is
interesting the the overall frequency of
execution is interesting so you know the
the authentication layer may have a very
large volume of a very large volume of
traffic but all of those executions are
basically the same we don't really need
to keep very many of them but relatively
rarely used services or operations may
surface more interesting patterns that
would be hard to detect by by a head
based sampling strategy and then there's
also some interesting there are some
interesting anomalies in the structure
of a trace
so does this execution tend to have a
particular graph shape and then if it if
it doesn't what does that mean or does
the does the vector of span counts tend
to be in a particular location in a
vector space and if we see a cluster
growing somewhere else does that mean
something about the about the execution
and so the challenge will be to develop
some ideas for a tale based sampling
while preserving some of the the virtues
of head based sampling namely the the
ease of implementation the not using
excess of resources and allowing for the
for the calculation of summary
statistics okay
so I'll try to communicate the the main
idea in a cartoon example so let's say
we we give ourselves a budget of thirty
thirty traces to keep every minute and
we have an application with three end
points get thing regenerate generally
receives about a thousand requests a
minute the median the median latency is
300 milliseconds create has a hundred
with a median of 400 and update as ten
with a meeting of 500 so the idea will
be to divide this budget up with the
preference for the infrequently used
endpoints so we have 30 let's give 15 to
get 10 to create and 5 to update and
then within each of them will prefer the
abnormally long or erroneous traces
so our target might be for example among
those 15 we're gonna keep forget for get
let's keep 3 under the median and 12
over for example for the other ones 2
and 8 and so on ok so this is a kind of
a cartoon of an algorithm so in a little
bit and we should do something similar
for for error rates but this is actually
a bit easier because we don't have to
track distributions it just counts so in
a little bit more detail we'll form a
sort of forecast for every endpoint you
can view this as a multivariate
forecasting problems problem so what is
the expected volume of traffic I should
receive for this endpoint in the next
minute divide up the budget among them
and then perform a kind of biased biased
sampling for each endpoint
okay and so maybe I'll I'll breeze
through this rather than you know use
allocation by the sort of Senate or
house rules will apply a concave
function to all of the all of the
contributions and then divide the budget
up that way instead and so one one
consequence of this is that you can see
parts of the in some cases you can see
parts of the micro-services architecture
that you may not otherwise have seen so
a common way to visualize a set of
traces is to sort of glue all of the
dependencies together into a graph to
see how to see how the data is flowing
through it and so first I'll first I
have here the graph corresponding the
the graph made from a set of traces that
were sampled via the head based strategy
so with some some fixed probability and
then taking into account the overall
frequency of execution we actually
discovered a new new service and then a
new dependency so of course it's sort of
easy to understand this what happened
theoretically but it also it happens in
real life okay so what we'd like to do -
to show to show a preference for the for
the traces and for traces and spans that
took longer than expected we need to be
able to answer questions like how
unusual is it for this operation to take
250 milliseconds to respond and so this
demands are sort of ranking data
structure so a data structure that can
support CDF or quantile type queries
should be neutral and representative so
even if our sampling is biased it should
reflect it should have the the correct
values that reflect the overall
population not just those we decided to
keep it would be great if it had a sense
of time maybe some kind of exponentially
exponentially weighted structure and of
course since we're since we want to make
this scalable the data structure should
be as small as possible it should also
be mirja below that if many machines are
operating this we can glue the results
together and still have and still have a
good estimate and it should be able to
operate incrementally so we can
incorporate one data point at
okay and this this leads us into the
into the world of data structures for
online quantile estimation and so I'll
just briefly show how how you would use
one of these so if you if you don't have
one of these maybe you are you're
allowed to keep you know 20 percent of a
particular end point you would sample
like this so the the horizontal axis is
the quantile space sorry if you know the
median maybe you would do something like
this show a preference for those that
took longer and if you knew the
distribution itself or some
approximation then you could sample like
this so the this is showing the the
probability of retention or the sampling
probability as a function of the
quantile okay and of course all of these
will will have the same integral so that
they were overall keeps a twenty percent
of the of the executions for an endpoint
okay and so if you use the green curve
what do you get well first let's so the
the blue curve is is head based sampling
and so if you if you run this on a data
set you might get a distribution that
looks like this and if instead you use
the green curve and show some preference
for the show some preference for the
right side of the distribution then you
get something that looks like this okay
so the the horizontal axes are almost
aligned the vertical axes are actually a
little bit different so I will say these
distributions look sort of tame but the
this is in log log axes and in general
these latency distributions have quite a
bit of positive skew which is which is
something we'll return to later okay so
there's similar there's a similar story
for errors so if you show a preference
for errors you can keep more of them and
so since there are maybe some I don't
know scientists or or mathematicians in
the audience you're probably saying well
thanks for the screenshots but you know
what is this work okay so
let's talk a little bit about different
data structures that can do ranking okay
so so what one proposal so without doing
any ranking one proposal would just be
to say maintain a rolling mean and
standard deviation and then make the the
sampling probability a function of the
z-score okay but this is not this
doesn't behave so well for distributions
with a lot of skew and possibly with a
large chunk of outliers so there's a way
to extend this to make it a little bit
more accurate and this is the so called
moment based quantile sketch so of
course if you have the first two moments
you don't know that much about the
distribution but if you know all of them
you can you can reconstruct the data set
and therefore and therefore any order
statistic but you could do something in
between which is keep a handful of the
moments and also some of the log moments
and then for all the distributions
realizing those moments pick the one
with the largest entropy and use that to
estimate quantiles okay and this is the
so-called moment based quantile sketch
and just like the the you know using
just the z-score you're maintaining just
a few statistics for each data set and
it's very easy to merge them so across
time or across space so so this has some
has some good properties we didn't use
this but it's it's something that's
that's out there another approach is to
use reservoir sampling so to keep just
to keep a sample where the the
probability of being in that sample
depends on where you are in time so if
you're very recent you have a high
probability of being in the sample if
you're older you're much less likely to
be around and then this device can be
used to support CDF and and quantile
type queries so this is another option
what we well we ended up using after
some experimentation is the so called
tea digest of of Dunning and Oertel and
this is basically a form of dynamic
histogram so rather than specify the the
bins in advance the bins sort of adapt
to the to the distribution as the as the
data arrives and so I'll spend a little
bit of time a little bit of time on this
so this is you can think of it as
maintaining a soar
list of centroids and a centroid is a
value and a weight and this represents a
certain number of points weight many
points that are near value okay there
are other implementations but you can
you can think of this as you can think
of this as an implementation and then if
you're asked to estimate a quantile if
you know the overall weight you just
sweep through the centroids and order or
maybe or maybe you do something more
intelligent until you've until you've
accumulated that much weight okay and so
the the permissible size of a centroid
is governed by a so called scale
function so this is a non decreasing
function from quantile space to the real
line and the requirement is that if if a
if a cluster occupies a certain range in
quantile space say q1 to q2 then the
difference between K of q1 + KF q2 so in
other words the length of the interval
after you apply the scale function has
to be less than or equal to 1 ok so it's
telling you how the how the cluster size
is allowed to grow as a function of the
quantile and the idea is that you can
keep smaller clusters in those parts of
the quantile space where you desire more
accuracy and allow the clusters to
become larger if you don't care about a
particular location and quantile space
okay so what are some scale functions so
let me disappoint you for a couple for a
couple seconds so how about 10 times Q
so this is just saying keep 10 bins with
roughly the same number of samples okay
that's what it's trying to do okay not
so interesting this is slightly more
interesting so now keep keep a thousand
bins okay it's gonna get better so here
here are some other scale functions so
here Delta is just some some positive
number that's kind of like the ten or
thousand in the previous slide and the
nice thing about scale functions like
this is that they have they have
variable accuracy in particular they are
extremely accurate towards the extremes
of the distribution right the the the
clusters are required to be very small
near the minimum and very small near the
maximum but
towards the median maybe we don't care
that much about the accuracy of our
estimates or we care less we want to
spend less memory and less computation
there and so we allow the clusters to be
larger okay so these are these already
appear in the in the original paper in
the original tea digest paper okay okay
and so I mentioned before that the
latency distributions have a significant
positive skew and this creates a desire
to have a data structure with asymmetric
accuracy so you don't really care what
the difference is between the first and
third percentile latency for example but
you may care a lot about the difference
between the 97th and 99th percentile so
that could affect whether or not you're
in violation of an SLA for example okay
and so if you're if you're given just
the single data set you know you can
specify your favorite scale function say
I don't care about anything less than
the median
give me one cluster and I care I care
really a lot about everything above the
90th percentile and you can compress it
with respect to some scale function the
the problem is that if you have two of
these you need to know that when you
merge them you will have the same error
bounds on the merged result and so it
actually didn't appear in the original
paper but in a follow-up paper
Dunning proved that for for these scale
functions and one other one which is
kind of similar to the log to the
logarithmic one if you have if you have
a digest with respect to that scale
function and you insert something the
resulting clustering continues to
satisfy the the size condition that the
the clusters have size less than or
equal to one
after you apply the function K and as a
consequence you can merge clusters and
retain the retain the error bounds okay
and that's just saying this so that if
you can merge two you can get a digest
on the Union and so the main problem is
that when you insert something or when
you merge to the location of a cluster
will change in the in the union of the
two datasets and you need to know that
its size doesn't grow too much as you
slide along in quantile space and so it
is actually a property of the scale
function
clusters continue to satisfy the
condition that they're not too large
after insertion and merging okay
and so I I felt this didn't have or I
couldn't find a proper theoretical
treatment and so I I came up with a
creative term decent and a definition
which just means that the function
itself and any positive scalar multiple
accepts insertions in the sense that if
you have a clustering with respect to
that scale function and make an
insertion the resulting clustering will
continue to satisfy the the scale
function the condition imposed by the
scale function and this turns out to be
equivalent to the condition that
whenever you have a pair of numbers in
quantile space which you can think of as
the balance for a cluster and a number
alpha which is going to be the
proportion occupied by the cluster you
insert that the difference between the
the values the endpoints of the new
cluster after the insertion those are
the primed ones is less than or equal to
the difference between the the values of
the original the endpoints of the
original cluster okay and there's sort
of two cases one is where you move to
the right the other is where you move to
the left but the the techniques don't
care too much about this distinction
okay so there's this characterization of
scale functions that we can use we can
sort of use in an emergent 'el way and
from this you can actually prove
something about scale functions so a
decent scale function has to be
continuous in fact differentiable so
this is my cartoon of the proof that
continuity is required so the I don't
know if you can see it the the black
dots represent the quantile bounds of a
cluster before insertion and the the red
dots have the primes those represent the
quantile bounds of a cluster after the
insertion and so the idea is that if you
can if you have a point of discontinuity
then you just imagine you have a cluster
very close to that point of
discontinuity where the difference
between K of Q 1 and K of Q 2 is very
small compared to the difference between
the values there the right and left hand
limits at the point of discontinuity
right and then you just make an
insertion that pushes exactly q2 but not
q1 over that line and then the K of Q 2
prime minus K of Q 1 prime will be much
bigger than K of Q 2 minus K of Q 1 ok
so and there's kind of a similar
argument for differentiability you you
have to handle the denominator as well
and you can and I and I wrote this up
it's not fascinating but it's true
and so this this requirement that a
decent scale function has to be
differentiable actually suggests a
construction which is that well we want
this asymmetric accuracy we care a lot
about one side of the distribution and
not the other why don't we pick some
point like 1/2 and instead of using you
know this arc sine or log of Q over 1
minus Q take the tangent line at some
point and extend the function that way
which is to say use one of these ok and
so if you if you imagine forming a
digest on a data set with respect to
either of these scale functions you can
see that the clusters will be relatively
large on the left hand side and become
progressively smaller as you move to the
right hand side okay so so that's just
that's just a suggestion and it turns
out to work so to actually verify this
if you think about the the inequality
involving the Q 1 Q 2 Q 1 prime Q 2
prime if you sort of rearrange it you
can write it as a one variable problem
you just have to verify that a couple of
functions are non increasing and that
you can do by calculus and I won't I
won't show you that I will I'll show you
some results instead
and so the it's actually sort of visible
ok
that's the surprise so the the top row
represents the results of digesting 1
million samples a hundred times on a
sort of traditional tea digest using the
log of Q over 1 minus Q scale function
and the second row represents the the
new version where we use the tangent
line construction on the on the
left-hand side okay so that that
explains the rose so the first column
represents the error so this is the
difference between the quantile we're
trying to approximate and the empirical
CDF of the estimated quantile and so the
the horizontal axis that's sorry that's
here the the horizontal you can almost
see it the the zero is the median minus
one and plus one our the tenth and 90th
percentiles and then 99th and so on and
that's also that also explains the
horizontal axis in the in the middle
column and so what you can see is that
for the for the log of Q over 1 minus Q
the sort of traditional tea digest the
the error is symmetric about the median
and if you normalize the error which is
to say divide it by the smaller of Q and
1 minus Q you have this you have this
nice shape and the I guess row-one
column-two
but if you instead use the glued version
where you allow the clusters to become
larger on the left hand side you you
have less accuracy on the left hand side
which is much more visible when you look
at the normalized error and of course
the so you've lost some accuracy you've
pretty much kept the same accuracy on
the right hand side and you've kept many
fewer centroids okay and to first order
the number of centroids is what controls
the the memory consumption of one of
these data structures okay and and
actually the it's kind of a side note
but you you actually save some CPU as
well because when you do the merging you
have to evaluate some transcendental
function and so now we only have to
evaluate it half of the time roughly we
have to evaluate just a linear function
on the left hand side so some some more
some more engineering goodness okay so
this is kind of the end of the story
with asymmetric T digest so this is the
one the one topic that I want to discuss
in the most depth and so maybe it's a
good time to just pause for a pause for
any questions
the central counts yes so alright so I
ran this experiment 100 times and so the
on the Left panels the it's a box and
whiskers plot from the fifth 95th and
then the interquartile range and the
median is in orange and then in each of
those runs you get a certain number of
centroids and I'm just showing the
histogram of the the number of centroids
and so in this case I use Delta equals
100 so generally the number of centroids
is is close to close to Delta and so if
you use the log of Q over 1 minus Q you
get it looks like 70 centroids most of
the time whereas if you use the
asymmetric version and allow compression
on the left hand side you keep about you
only have to keep about 40 centroids
yeah so sorry yeah the horizontal axis
on the rightmost column is yeah number
of centroids in the data structure
okay so maybe should we discuss one more
topic so that as I explained to mark the
talk is kind of designed it's easily
truncate a bowl so you can stop it at
any point and hopefully makes sense so
there's another topic which we which we
can discuss but once we start it we have
to finish it so so one problem is that
you know when you intentionally bias
your sampling you know you you you show
a preference for the the traces that
took longer than you expected and then
you for example calculate a percentile
on that data set it's wrong and you
would like to know what the baseline
what the the baseline actually is and we
would like some some accurate
characterization of the steady state and
so the way we solve this is to also
record the sampling probability when we
decide to retain a trace and so to kind
of demonstrate how this works you can
imagine a generator spitting out
examples from a distribution and
recording the truth a sampler that keeps
a biased sample say 10% maybe according
to the the green curve from some slides
ago and then you can compare these okay
so I take yeah there's a there's a data
set very cool there's a weighted sample
according to the green curve or
something qualitatively very similar so
we we really try to keep the the long
guys and then when you use the if you
record also the sampling probability
then you you kind of have the same thing
and you show this to people and they're
like it looks great and you know that's
probably not good enough for you
so to just say a little bit about the
quantitative methodology one way to
measure the difference between
distributions is the relative entropy
which is kind of saying in this case how
much information do you lose if you pass
from the full data set to the weighted
sample that you've decided to retain
okay so it's it's a certain it's a
certain integral this is by the way a
non-negative number and it's zero
exactly when when P and Q are the same
which is to say the the distributions
are the same and it's not symmetric
so then what you can do is say well if I
start with the full dataset and
construct a uniform random sample with
with the same sampling probability say
10% I can understand I understand
roughly how much information is lost and
I can compare that to the biased sample
so in other words I calculate first the
the relative entropy between the full
dataset the truth and a sample
constructed by sampling uniformly at
random to the the relative entropy of
relative entropy of the the full dataset
with regard to the weighted sample with
the same sampling rates and what you'll
find is that these distributions are
very similar and you can actually see
where they disagree right because this
is kind of a function of the the
distribution function of the of the full
sample it's an expectation with respect
to with respect to that distribution and
this also allows you to understand how
the confidence intervals behave in
particular when you do this weighted
sampling your confidence intervals are
relatively tight towards the right-hand
side of the distribution and and much
looser towards the the left-hand side of
the distribution but that's exactly what
we want because we don't really care
about those first percentile executions
and those differences are are very small
in in in relative terms anyway okay so I
think I think this is probably a good
place to probably a good place to stop
but I'll I'll say who stay up here if
there are some questions and then I'll
I'll be available for for a while on
office hours I guess
you have example of result when you
calculate the above I burn divergence
right like for example the previous
slide you have like a new network if you
look at the no I I don't have I don't
have any results for this one they are
somewhere there just not in this there
not in this slide a what do you remember
the kind of rank of number because
sometimes it's it's kind of because of
the log and things like that like it's
it's sometime even when they look very
similar like that number you get like
it's not so much yeah so so the numbers
themselves are small small positive
numbers I know that's kind of a
meaningless statement I think this also
depends on the units of information you
use but they're relatively small
positive numbers so actually there's it
yeah there's a the joke is that you
calculate this for the the weighted
sample and then you go to your product
manager and say I got a relative entropy
of point 0 0 0 1 is that good enough
that was the joke and you get you
calculated from the histogram so so in
this case we so the this is you can
think of this as an expectation with
respect to the the the empirical density
of the full sample a cap capital capital
and lowercase P correspond to the full
sample so you're kind of doing you an
empirical distribution you don't out
like the continuous
and you cannot really do the the
integral per se you do it as a histogram
just like adding the area of the
rectangle yeah that's right I mean you
do some numerical integration yeah I
mean in fact the yeah the samples are
drawn from some fixed distribution so
you you could do it as a continuous
integral I don't think that would change
the results very much yeah but so you
basically calculate this for P is equal
to the full data set and Q is equal to a
random sample and compare that to P is
equal to the full data set q is equal to
the weighted sample
[Music]